لقد تعلمنا في السنوات الأخيرة أن
تشيلسي ليس نادٍ يسمح للعاطفة بأن تقف في
طريق
سعيهم للحصول على الألقاب وقد اتضح
أنه حتى مع الهداف القياسي الذي سجله
فرانك لامبارد لم يسبق له مثيل
على مر السنين إلى أي
مدى
يمكن أن يكونوا قساة.  أن يكون في ملعب ستامفورد بريدج وحتى
مع مكانته كلاعب على الرغم
من حقيقة أنه
قادهم إلى نهائي كأس الاتحاد الإنجليزي الموسم الماضي ، فقد حقق
فريقه مؤخرًا في
الدوري الممتاز خمس هزائم في
ثماني
مباريات بالطريقة التي خرجوا بها من
المنافسة على اللقب.  إعادة
تكافح من أجل التأهل لدوري الأبطال الموسم المقبل
يعني أن المالك رومان أبراموفيتش قد قرر
تخصيص وقت
في فترته بعد 18 شهرًا في القيادة ،
كانت دائمًا مهمة صعبة
لمدير شاب في مركزه الثاني
بدوام كامل فقط
لأول مرة في.  الدوري الممتاز والضغط زاد
فقط من خلال الإنفاق الصيفي الكبير
على أمثال عادات كاي
وتيمو فيرنا أماندا ديفيس سي إن إن لندن